This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you listen to the show for a while, you know that we're big fans of icons and symbols and signage. And one of the main places you encounter those is on the road. So in our ongoing ubiquitous icon series, we're taken to the highways. I'm thinking we should call this one, Highways 101. You know? I like it. You know?
这里是《99%不可思议》，我是罗马·马斯。如果你听过这个节目一段时间，你就会知道我们非常喜欢各种图标、符号和标牌。你遇到这些东西的主要场所之一就是道路上。因此，在我们持续进行的无处不在的图标系列中，我们要走上高速公路。我想我们应该把这一期叫做《高速公路 101》。你知道吗？我喜欢它。你知道吗？
I like it. I like it. Highway 101. That's Kurt Colesde, he's our digital director and co-author of the book, The 99% of Physical City. One of the things Kurt does is he checks our inbox for listener submitted ideas, comings to all of them. And earlier this summer,
我喜欢它。我喜欢它。101 号公路。那是科特·科尔斯德，他是我们的数字总监，也是《物理城市的 99%》一书的合著者。科特的工作之一就是查看我们的收件箱，里面有听众提交的想法，其中包含各种各样的主意。今年夏天早些时候，
a 99-Pi fan named Daniel wrote us about a strange stop sign that he encountered while traveling and you started digging into the story. Yeah, so his email started like this. A couple of years ago, we took a trip to Hawaii and my wife became obsessed over a few blue stop signs we saw in parking lots. The signs were the size and shape and use the same lettering as normal red stop signs, but they were bright blue.
一位名叫丹尼尔的 99-Pi 粉丝给我们写信，讲述了他在旅行中遇到的一块奇怪的停车标志，然后你开始深入研究这个故事。对，所以他的电子邮件是这样开始的。几年前，我们去夏威夷旅行，我妻子迷上了我们在停车场看到的几个蓝色停车标志。这些标志的大小、形状以及使用的字母都与正常的红色停车标志相同，但它们是亮蓝色的。
So, I don't think I've ever seen that before. and use the same lettering as normal red stop signs, but they were bright blue. So I don't think I've ever seen that before. I had never seen this either, either in images or in real life. So I started looking into why some were blue, and that turned out to be pretty easy to figure out. But it got me wondering something a lot more fundamental, which is, why are the rest of the red, right?
所以，我想我以前从来没有见过那样的东西。并且使用的字母与普通的红色停车标志相同，但它们是亮蓝色的。所以我认为我以前从未见过那样东西。我也从未见过这样的标志，无论是在图片中还是在现实生活中。所以我开始调查为什么有些是蓝色的，结果证明这很容易弄清楚。但这让我开始思考一些更根本的问题，那就是，为什么其余的都是红色的呢？
Like, why is that such a thing in the first place? Uh, totally. Yeah, and that got me into, of course, digging into the whole history of stop signs. Of course, of course, that's the only way this is going to go with you. Yeah, it's just my nature. And as I was looking into this, this one figure kept popping up everywhere I looked.
比如，为什么一开始这会成为一种现象？呃，完全是这样。是的，这促使我开始深入研究停车标志的整个历史。当然，当然，你肯定会朝着这个方向去了解。是的，这就是我的天性。当我研究这个问题时，我发现有一个人物不断在我看到的各个地方出现。
A guy named William Phelps, you know, who in the early 1900s became known as the Father of Traffic Safety. Huh. Okay, so what do you have to do to earn that title, the Father of Traffic Safety? So, you know, it was born way back in the 1850s, and if you think about it, you know, 1850s is in New York,
一个叫威廉·菲尔普斯的人，你知道的，他在 20 世纪初被称为“交通安全之父”。呵。好吧，那么你必须做些什么才能赢得“交通安全之父”这个称号呢？所以，你知道，他出生于 1850 年代，如果你仔细想想，你知道，1850 年代是在纽约，
this is in New York without cars. So, of course, it's in New York without stop signs. That stop signs totally. Yeah. The roads back then were kind of this open space that was shared by curages and pedestrians, and they've moved all around. It was a lot different.
这是没有汽车的纽约。所以，当然，这是一个没有停车标志的纽约。那是绝对没有停车标志的。是的。那时的道路有点像一种开放空间，由马车和行人共享，他们到处移动。情况大不相同。
Right, right. And there was like some attempts to do some traffic management and stuff, but it was all kind of ad hoc, and like, you know, people standing in the street, and it wasn't very organized. It all got worse, right? As more technologies evolved, and more and more people were in the street and it wasn't very organized. It all got worse, right? As more technologies evolved
对，对。当时有一些尝试来进行交通管理之类的事情，但都是即兴的，比如，你知道，人们站在街上，并不是很有组织。情况变得更糟了，对吧？随着越来越多的技术发展，越来越多的人在街上，而且并不是很有组织。情况变得更糟了，对吧？随着越来越多的技术发展，
and more and more people were on the streets and cars started showing up. And it just was increasingly clear that this was a mess and it was going to need some kind of regulation. And so was it, you know, some kind of road expert? Is that what he was working on? Well, that's the thing.
越来越多的人走上街头，汽车也开始出现。人们越来越清楚地意识到，这是一个烂摊子，需要某种形式的规制。那么，他是某种道路专家吗？这就是他当时在从事的工作吗？嗯，这就是关键所在。
Not really. He came from this family real estate business, decided it wasn't for him, wasn't his passion. His passion was traffic. So in 1900, he writes this article and it's not entirely clear in hindsight if he realized what he was doing at the time, but he basically was writing a treatise
并非如此。他出身于一个家族房地产企业，觉得这不适合他，也不是他的激情所在。他的激情是交通。所以在 1900 年，他写了一篇文章，回顾过去时，并不完全清楚他当时是否意识到自己在做什么，但他基本上是在撰写一篇论文，
that would lay the groundwork for everything he would do for the rest of his life. So in the end, he would come around to inventing and evolving all different kinds of traffic innovations, things we take for granted today, like road rejoctions and pedestrian crossing. Wow, so he really earned that title, the father of traffic safety.
为他余生所做的一切奠定了基础。因此，最终他将发明和发展各种不同的交通创新，也就是我们今天认为理所当然的事情，比如道路交叉口和人行横道。哇，所以他真的赢得了“交通安全之父”这个称号。
Absolutely. And once his ideas got some traction in the US, he began helping other cities create traffic plans. And some really recognizable designs trace back to him, like roundabouts at Piccadilly Circus in London, and around the Arctodtriumph in Paris. And he was even inducted into the Legion of Honor by the French government after World War I. For traffic? Yes. That's what he got that. Wow. He essentially got, you know, France is
绝对是的。一旦他的想法在美国得到一些关注，他就开始帮助其他城市制定交通规划。一些极具辨识度的设计都可以追溯到他，比如伦敦皮卡迪利广场的环岛，以及巴黎凯旋门周边的环岛。甚至在第一次世界大战后，他还被法国政府授予荣誉军团勋章。因为交通？是的。他就是因为这个获奖的。哇。他基本上得到了，你知道的，法国
equivalent of a knighthood for traffic design. But if you think about it from their perspective, his traffic designs help get French troops to the front lines, which in turn helped them hold off the Germans during the war. France is pushing like 60,000 troops towards Verdun to hold the German advance towards Paris. It was all made possible by this guy's traffic planning. And so was Eno the man who entered the stop sign? Well, that's the thing. I kind of
相当于交通设计领域的爵士头衔。但如果你从他们的角度来考虑，他的交通设计帮助法国军队到达前线，这反过来又帮助他们在战争期间抵挡住了德国人。法国正向凡尔登推进大约 6 万名军队，以阻挡德军向巴黎推进。这一切都得益于这家伙的交通规划。那么，埃诺就是发明停车标志的人吗？嗯，这就是问题所在。我有点
fell down this rabbit hole looking into him. But one thing I realized along the way was that I was never going to find the inventor of the stop sign. Yeah. Because it's one of those things that has existed in various forms for a while now. But it's safe to say that Eno played a really big role in popularizing stop signs and yield signs and that kind of signage infrastructure. And that's why his name comes up so much
在研究他时陷入了这个兔子洞。但我在这一过程中意识到的一件事是，我永远也找不到停车标志的发明者。是的。因为这是那种以各种形式存在了一段时间的事物之一。但可以肯定的是，埃诺在推广停车标志、让行标志以及这类标牌基础设施方面发挥了非常大的作用。这就是为什么当你调查这些事情时，他的名字会如此频繁地出现。
when you're looking into these things. And also, you know, put this in context, right? Stop signs back then they weren't what we think of as stop signs today. They're designs varied from place to place. What are the first ones that popped up in Detroit? And I think it was 1915 had black lettering on a white background. Presumably for contrast.
而且，你知道，把这个放在当时的背景下，对吧？当时的停车标志并不是我们今天所认为的停车标志。它们的设计因地而异。底特律最早出现的一些标志是什么样子的？我想那是 1915 年，白底黑字。大概是为了形成对比吧。
So they really, they came in all these different shapes and sizes. And there was no sort of one person you could say, aha, that guy made the stop sign. Yeah, I mean, I think that makes sense to me that there would be a need for stop signs and therefore they would be invented in multiple places and multiple times. So when did they sort of get this octagonal shape that we attribute to them?
所以它们确实有各种不同的形状和大小。而且没有哪一个人可以说是“啊哈，那家伙制作了停车标志”。是的，我的意思是，我认为这对我来说很有意义，那就是会有对停车标志的需求，因此它们会在多个地方、多个时间被发明出来。那么它们是什么时候变成我们所熟知的八角形形状的呢？
Like when did that happen? Right, so that one actually does have a specific answer. And the answer is 1923. That's with the Mississippi Valley Association of State Highway Departments decided to standardize the shape. That's a very specific answer. And it was a pretty good idea to make it a non-standard shape, something that would stand out, but there was actually more to it than that. They had this idea that they could create an association
比如那是何时发生的？对，所以那个实际上有一个具体的答案。答案是 1923 年。那是密西西比州公路局协会决定统一形状的时候。这是一个非常具体的答案。把形状做成非标准的、能脱颖而出的形状是个好主意，但实际上还有更多原因。他们有一个想法，就是可以在
between geometry and safety. Explain more of what you mean there. Well, they believed that the shape itself could communicate something. Like part of what the sign was trying to do could be achieved through the shape of that sign. Okay, so we're not talking about just associating a rare shape with a specific meaning.
几何形状和安全性之间建立一种联系。请多解释一下你这里的意思。嗯，他们相信形状本身可以传达一些东西。比如标志试图实现的一部分功能可以通过该标志的形状来实现。好吧，所以我们讨论的不仅仅是将一个罕见的形状与特定含义联系起来。
They actually, there's some kind of theory behind eight having a meaning that ties to stopping. Yes, and this was a huge surprise to me. Yeah, because it sounds like nonsense. It sounds right. It sounds sort of occult almost, right? Don't wait. But I found it. I found this out through this New York Times magazine article by Hillary Greenbaum and
他们实际上在数字“八”具有与停止相关的含义背后有一些理论支撑。是的，这对我来说是个巨大的惊喜。是的，因为听起来像无稽之谈。听起来很对。听起来几乎有点神秘，对吧？等等，别急。但我找到了。我是通过希拉里·格林鲍姆（Hillary Greenbaum）和
Deeter Rubenstein. And I'm just going to have you read this excerpt for context that explains why the highway departments association recommended different shapes for different science. Okay, here it is. Quote, the recommendations were based on a simple albeit not exactly intuitive idea. The more sides a sign has, the higher the danger level it invokes. By the engineers reckoning, the circle, which has an infinite number of sides, screamed danger and was recommended for railroad crossings. The octagon with its eight sides was used
迪特·鲁宾斯坦（Deeter Rubenstein）在《纽约时报杂志》上的一篇文章发现这一点的。为了便于理解，我将请你朗读这段摘录，它解释了为什么公路局协会建议对不同的标志采用不同的形状。好的，内容如下：“引文：这些建议基于一个简单却并非完全直观的想法。标志的边越多，它唤起的危险级别就越高。据工程师估算，拥有无限多条边的圆圈发出了危险的信号，因此被推荐用于铁路交叉口。拥有八个边的八角形被用来
to denote the second highest level. The diamond shape was for warning signs and the rectangle and square shapes were used for informational signs. End quote. That is just wild. It really is, right? I mean, there's so many things that I have,
表示第二高的级别。菱形用于警告标志，长方形和正方形则用于信息标志。”结束引文。这真是太疯狂了。确实如此，对吧？我的意思是，我有太多的事情，
so many questions I have about this. And one of which is like, it's a circle really have an infinite number of sides. Well, yeah, so I'm thinking back to like, you know, grade school geometry. And I'm like, I mean, I think that there's something to that. I think it's like, yeah, there's, if you take the tangent of each point,
我有太多关于这个的问题了。其中之一就是，圆圈真的有无限多条边吗？嗯，是的，所以我在回想比如小学几何。然后我想，我的意思是，我认为这其中有一定道理。我想这就像是，是的，如果你取每个点的切线，
and therefore it has an infinite number of sides, but I don't think people perceive it as having an infinite number of sides. I think they presented it as having one side. Right. It's not like we look at a circle, a square, a triangle, and we say, aha, right. Three, four, and infinite. It never in a million years occurred to me that there was some grand geometric theory behind US stop sign shapes. But if you think about it, if you start to unpack it and you look at signs around you, you can sort of understand what they're getting at, right? It's like, well, yeah, rectangular signs often tell you like what exit to take or something. There's circles at railroad crossing, sure. Yeah, but there's also like arm bars at railroad crossings.
因此它有无限多条边，但我不认为人们将它感知为具有无限多条边。我认为他们认为它只有一条边。对。我们看一个圆、一个正方形、一个三角形时，并不是说，啊哈，对吧？三、四和无限。我做梦也没有想到美国停车标志形状背后有什么宏大的几何理论。但如果你仔细想想，如果你开始剖析它并观察你周围的标志，你就能大致理解他们的意图，对吧？就像，嗯，对，长方形标志通常告诉你该走哪个出口之类的事情。铁路交叉口有圆圈，当然。是的，但铁路交叉口也有栏杆。
Like because the circle is not quite enough sometimes. There's also exes and rhombars and all kinds of other things. So I get that there's a theory behind it. And if it has some kind of basis and semiotics, I'm willing to entertain that notion. So now that in 1923 in Mississippi, they established the shape. How did they come up with the red background?
因为有时候圆圈还远远不够。还有叉号、菱形栏杆和各种其他东西。所以我明白这背后有一种理论。如果它在符号学上有某种基础，我愿意接受这种观点。所以既然他们在 1923 年在密西西比州确立了形状，他们又是如何想出红色背景的呢？
Well, that might seem like the simpler decision. That would actually took a while longer. At the time, yellow was often used, apart just from material science reasons, like they couldn't get a really good reflective, durable red. And so yellow showed up all at night. So for decades, that was the general standard. And then in the 1950s, they made red the official stand.
嗯，这看起来可能是个更简单的决定。但这实际上花了更长的时间。当时，黄色经常被使用，部分原因只是出于材料科学的原因，比如他们无法获得真正具有高反射性、耐用性的红色。因此黄色在夜间也很显眼。因此，几十年来，这一直是普遍的标准。然后在 20 世纪 50 年代，他们将红色定为官方标准。
Okay, so yellow because you can make kind of a matte yellow and it contrasts really well with black, for example, and it looks really good at night. But until you get that shiny red that you see on a stop sign, red is not a very good stop sign color. Right, and if you think about like, when you see a red stop sign at night, but until you get that shiny red that you see on a stop sign, red is not a very good stop sign color. Right. And if you think about like, when you see a red stop sign at night, it is really shiny
好吧，所以选择黄色是因为你可以制造出一种哑光黄色，例如它与黑色形成很好的对比，而且在夜间看起来非常好。但是，直到你拥有停车标志上那种闪亮的红色之前，红色并不是一个很好的停车标志颜色。对，而且如果你考虑到——当你晚上看到一个红色的停车标志时，但在你得到停车标志上那种闪亮的红色之前，红色并不是一个很好的停车标志颜色。对。而且如果你考虑到——当你晚上看到一个红色的停车标志时，它是非常闪亮的
and really reflective. And also by that time too, you know, we've got stop lights and other signage and red has really got this built up association of being a thing telling you to stop. So making them red just kind of fit with the grander scheme of everything else that was going out at the time. Yeah, and it's a warning color in nature, I suppose yellow is too, but yeah, it makes sense. So how does this, you know, get us to those blue stop signs and why the Daniel found?
且反光极佳。而且到那个时候，你知道，我们已经有了红绿灯和其他标牌，红色在人们心中已经真正建立起一种“告诉你停下来”的关联。所以将它们设计成红色，正好符合当时正在进行的其他一切宏大计划。是的，而且它在自然界中是一种警告色，我想黄色也是，但是的，这说得通。那么，这怎么能，你知道，把我们引向丹尼尔发现的那些蓝色停车标志呢？
Oh, right. And that's how we come full circle or full octagon as a poor. And it turns out the blue painted stop signs are actually exceptional on purpose. You usually find them on private property, places like store parking lots, and the reason they're blue is so they won't be confused with other official government red sides. That makes sense. So they're like intentional fakes because they don't want it to seem like it's a sign maintained by the city or county. So they're like malt cops. They're kind of different. They have a badge, they might have a gun, but they're not actual cops.
哦，对。这就是我们兜了一个大圈，或者说兜了一个八角形的大圈。事实证明，故意把停车标志漆成蓝色是有特殊原因的。你通常在私人物品上看到它们，比如商店停车场，它们之所以是蓝色的，是为了不与政府其他官方的红色标志混淆。这说得通。所以它们就像是故意伪造的，因为它们不想让人觉得这是由城市或县维护的标志。所以它们就像是假警察。它们有点不同。它们有徽章，可能还有枪，但它们不是真正的警察。
Yeah, right. Like whether you actually decide to pay attention to what the signs telling you is a little bit up to you. But it is really clear what it's trying to tell you, right? Yeah, I mean, that's one of the things I think it's so great about the stompsign is that with the shape, the word stop and the color, you can really take one or two of those elements and at this point, it'll convey the meaning. If you had a red octagon with no word, stop on it. I think people would generally stop.
是的，对。就像你实际上是否决定听从标志告诉你的内容，有点取决于你自己。但它试图告诉你的内容非常明确，对吧？是的，我的意思是，我认为停车标志最棒的地方之一就是，凭借它的形状、单词“STOP”和颜色，你真的只需要其中一个或两个元素，在这一点上，它就能传达含义。如果你有一个没有任何文字的红色八角形，上面写着“停止”。我想人们通常也会停下来。
Right. Or if you saw an octagon from behind, you'll know that that's a stop somewhere. The other people have to stop. Yeah. Yeah. That's a good sign. So they were onto something in Mississippi in 1923. And they figured something out.
对。或者如果你从后面看到一个八角形，你就会知道那是某处需要停车的地方。其他人必须停下来。是的。是的。这是一个好标志。所以他们在 1923 年的密西西比州确实有所发现。他们弄懂了一些事情。
That's so cool. Yeah. There we go. Yeah. And I actually have another blue sign for you. Okay. This one is actually not so much of an exception as the rule. So a blue sign, but not a stop sign. So what which one are you talking about? Right. So the ones I'm talking about are these big rectangular, super recognizable ones
太酷了。是的。就是这样。是的。我其实还有另一个蓝色标志要给你。好的。这个实际上与其说是例外，不如说是规则。所以是一个蓝色标志，但不是停车标志。那么你在说哪一个呢？对。我所说的是那些大型的、长方形的、超级容易辨认的标志，
that if you've ever driven between cities you have seen one of these They're those big blue signs that tell you which businesses are at which exits. Oh, yeah When you're traveling these are the greatest signs ever because this is where you get to check out like if there's like an in-and-out burger That exit or you have to keep going because there's nothing good to eat exactly like they're super easy to going because there's nothing good to eat. Exactly. They're super easy to recognize. You know what they look like? You know what they're telling you.
如果你在城市之间开车，你一定见过其中一个。它们是那些巨大的蓝色标志，告诉你哪个出口有哪些企业。哦，是的。当你旅行时，这些是最棒的标志，因为在这里你可以查看比如那个出口是否有In-N-Out汉堡，或者你是否必须继续前行，因为那里没有什么好吃的。完全正确，就像它们超级容易……必须继续前行，因为那里没有什么好吃的。完全正确。它们超级容易辨认。你知道它们长什么样。你知道它们在告诉你什么。
They're generally called specific service signs. There are actually three different types of them. One of the ones is the one that you just mentioned, which is the mainline sign. That tells you where to get off for what. Then there are these smaller ramp signs that you see when you drive up the off ramp and then there are these smaller trailblazer signs and all of these are designed to route you to the exact place you're trying to get. Right. And so I've always kind of wondered like how those signs work. I mean who gets to be on them? Because not every business at the accident is on one. And they really do serve as your guide to the road. So how does that all happen?
它们通常被称为特定服务标志。其实有三种不同类型。其中一种就是你刚才提到的主线标志。它告诉你应该在哪个出口下高速。然后是当你驶下匝道时看到的较小的匝道标志，接着是更小的指路标志，所有这些标志的设计都是为了引导你到达你试图去的准确地点。对。所以我一直有点好奇这些标志是如何运作的。我的意思是，谁能上这些标志？因为出口处的每一家企业都不在标志上。它们确实起到了道路向导的作用。这一切是怎么发生的呢？
They're pretty standard looking from state to state. But the details of how they work can vary quite a lot. But the big idea is that businesses have to meet certain criteria to get a spot on these signs. So for example, they may need to be open a certain number of hours per day and days per week and weeks per year. They might have to have a certain minimum capacity for patrons, a certain number of seats and bathrooms, a certain number of parking spots. And these requirements can get really specific. Like restaurants in Kentucky
从一个州到另一个州，它们看起来非常标准。但它们的运作细节可能会有很大差异。不过核心理念是，企业必须满足某些标准才能在这些标志上获得一个位置。例如，它们可能需要每天营业一定小时数、每周营业一定天数、每年营业一定周数。它们可能必须对顾客有一定的最低容纳量，一定数量的座位和洗手间，一定数量的停车位。这些要求可能会变得非常具体。就像肯塔基州的餐馆
have to be open and serve water from 7 a.m. to 10 p.m. Okay, so that's actually really great so that you know that there's a basic level of service. And so do you get on the sign if you meet those requirements basically? Well, it depends. It depends in part on demand. In some places, businesses have to get at the back of a line basically and wait to get their spot on the sign. They also have to develop versions of their logos
必须在早上 7 点到晚上 10 点营业并提供水。好吧，这其实真的很棒，这样你就知道有了一个基本的服务水平。那么，如果你满足了这些要求，基本上就能上标志了吗？嗯，这得看情况。这部分取决于需求。在某些地方，企业基本上必须排到队伍的末尾，等待在标志上获得自己的位置。它们还必须开发出符合
that fit within the dimensions of the box, which of course, standardized on the sign. And then depending upon the location and the size of the sign and the type of sign, you might actually have to pay hundreds or thousands of dollars a year to get a prime placement on one of these. Wow. So it really is like a paid advertisement after all? It is, but there's some more nuance to it too. Like in Oregon, there are discounts for non-profit organizations that want space on a sign. And in California, some of the sign revenue gets set aside and put towards creating and
标志尺寸的标志内框版本的徽标，当然，标志上的尺寸是标准化的。然后，根据位置、标志大小和标志类型的不同，你实际上可能每年要支付数百或数千美元才能在其中一个标志上获得黄金位置。哇。所以它毕竟真的就像付费广告一样？是的，但其中也有更多细微差别。例如，在 Oregon（俄勒冈州），想要在标志上获得空间的非营利组织可以享受折扣。在 California（加利福尼亚州），部分标志收入会被留出来，用于创建和
maintaining rest areas, which is a really nice public service. You know, some of us are just geeks, and we like learning about these things. But for people who are on the road a lot, this is really useful information, right? You know when you look at the sign, if you know the rules for the state, you know what to expect from the stop. That the businesses there will offer certain things and be open at certain times and be within a certain distance to the exit. And all that's really handy if you're somebody who spends a lot of time on the road. Right. And if you're really thirsty and Kentucky, you know if you see a bread drawn on that sign, you can pull over and get a drink of water. That's right, but only for 14 hours a day.
维护休息区，这是一项非常好的公共服务。你知道，我们有些人只是极客，我们喜欢了解这些事情。但对于经常在路上开车的人来说，这是非常有用的信息，对吧？你知道当你看着这个标志时，如果你知道这个州的规则，你就知道对这个停车点有什么期待。那里的企业会提供某些东西，在特定时间营业，并且距离出口在一定距离之内。对于经常在路上花大量时间的人来说，所有这些都非常方便。对。如果你在肯塔基州真的很渴，你知道如果在那个标志上看到一个面包的图案，你就可以把车停下来喝杯水。没错，但一天只能持续 14 小时。
So we're going to pull off the freeway and the big blue signs onto kind of a rural route highway for our next ubiquitous icon. And this is really kind of not so much an icon is an object that became an icon. And it is the mailbox. And it's the specific kind of mailbox. It's that metal, flat bottom rounded top, a little red flag on the side. If you live in the US, you definitely see one of these. You raise or lower the flag. If you have outgoing mail, I mean, this thing is truly ubiquitous. Right. And even if you don't live in the US, you know what they look like, because you've seen them in graphic format, you've seen them in pictures. These things became a digit like on a long time
所以我们要把车从高速公路和大蓝牌子上开下来，转到一条乡村公路上，去寻找我们下一个无处不在的图标。这其实与其说是一个图标，不如说是一个变成了图标的物体。它就是邮箱。而且它是那种特定种类的邮箱。它是那种金属材质、平底圆顶、侧面带有一面小红旗的邮箱。如果你住在美国，你绝对见过其中一个。你升起或放下旗帜。如果你有要寄出的信件，我的意思是，这个东西真的是无处不在。对。即使你不住在美国，你也知道它们长什么样，因为你在图形格式中见过它们，你在图片中见过它们。这些东西很久很久以前
ago. But in terms of the physical box, well, it's a pretty simple and elegant solution. But it grew out of this really long history of problems that the United States Postal Service was having. And it didn't actually come out until 1915, but to understand it, we have to go back another half century or so to 1863. And that's the year that the USPS introduced free city delivery. So I think of the US Postal Services having universal access so that you get mail delivered no matter where you are. We did a whole episode about that sort of thing. Right. Right.
就变成了数字化的标志。但就实体信箱而言，嗯，这是一个非常简单而优雅的解决方案。但它是从美国邮政服务公司长期面临的一系列问题中发展而来的。它直到 1915 年才真正问世，但要理解它，我们必须将时间倒回大约半个世纪到 1863 年。那是 USPS 引入免费城市投递的一年。所以我认为美国邮政服务拥有普遍接入权，无论你在哪里都能收到信件。我们为此制作了一整集节目。对。对。
But universal access doesn't mean universal access to mail at your front door. And that was the sort of key innovation that that created a little bit of rift between city dwellers and people who didn't live in cities. Oh, so people who lived in cities because they're close together, they got their mail delivered to their door. But people who lived out in the country did not get that luxury. Right, right. And it makes sense, right? They can go door to door much more easily in the city than they can in the country. And so this was a big boon to people who were living in cities. But if you think about when we are, you know, in the 1800s, most people aren't living in urban areas at this point. They're all spread out.
但普遍接入并不意味着信件能普遍送达你家前门。这就是那种引发了城里人和不住在城市里的人之间一点裂痕的关键创新。哦，所以住在城里的人因为住得近，他们的信件可以直接送到门口。但住在乡下的人就没有这种奢侈的待遇。对，对。这说得通，对吧？他们在城里挨家挨户送信比在乡村要容易得多。所以这对住在城里的人来说是一大福利。但如果你想想我们所在的时期，你知道，在 1800 年代，大多数人当时并不住在城市地区。他们都分散在各处。
And so the standard practice was that they would go to their local post office if they wanted to pick up or send mail. Yeah. Which is why you see all these like really beautiful little rural post offices around. I like I subscribe to a Twitter account that just shows you pictures. I really love them. I love it. No, me too.
因此标准的做法是，如果他们想取信或寄信，他们会去当地的邮局。是的。这就是为什么你会看到所有这些非常漂亮的小乡村邮局。我喜欢——我订阅了一个推特账号，上面只展示它们的照片。我真的很喜欢它们。我很喜欢。不，我也是。
I love these tiny little post offices of all shapes and sizes. But of course, if you're thinking about it from a practical standpoint, all these people living out in the countryside aren't totally thrilled that they're paying the same postage rates as people in the city, but aren't getting the same level of service, right? They're not getting this door-to-door service like city dollars are. Yeah, I can imagine them getting pretty upset with that. So how did this tension eventually resolve?
我喜欢这些各种形状和大小的微型邮局。但当然，如果你从实用主义的角度来考虑，所有这些住在乡下的人并不是很高兴他们支付和城里人一样的邮费，却没有得到同等水平的服务，对吧？他们没有像城里人那样获得这种门到门的服务。是的，我可以想象他们对此会非常生气。那么这种紧张关系最终是如何解决的呢？
Right. So finally, in 1896, the USPS starts testing out rural free delivery. That solved some problems and created others because suddenly farmers and other people living outside of cities were just cobbling together mailboxes from whatever was handy like large cans and feed crates and cigar boxes and basically they just would take anything that was box-like and pick it up and nail it to a post. I love it.
对。所以最终，在 1896 年，USPS 开始试行乡村免费投递。这解决了一些问题，但也产生了一些其他问题，因为突然之间，农民和居住在城市以外的其他人群开始用手头任何顺手的东西拼凑邮箱，比如大号罐头、饲料箱和雪茄盒，基本上他们会拿任何像箱子一样的东西，捡起来钉在木桩上。我喜欢这个。
I do too, honestly. I mean, I can imagine that being a bit of a pain because you have to figure out like if you're a postal carrier, like, is this thing nailed to a post a mailbox, or is it something else, or is it like a peach basket for basketball, for example? Right, right. And everyone, you know, they might open differently like, you know, there's no standardization here. And so, yeah, the USPS ends up having to impose standards. And they started requiring boxes be purpose-built for mail that they be made of metal, The purpose built for mail that they made of metal resistant to snow and rain have some kind of flag or signal to indicate that there's outgoing mail inside.
我也是，说实话。我的意思是，我可以想象这会有点麻烦，因为你必须弄清楚——如果你是一个邮递员，这东西钉在木桩上是一个邮箱，还是其他什么东西，或者比如它是一个用于打篮球的桃子篮？对，对。而且每个人，你知道，它们的打开方式可能不同，就像，你知道，这里没有标准化。所以，是的，USPS 最终不得不强加标准。他们开始要求邮箱必须是专门为信件制造的，它们必须由金属制成，专门为信件制造、由金属制成、能够抵抗冰雪和雨水、有某种旗帜或信号来表明里面有要寄出的信件。
And of course, they be high up enough that they can be reached from vehicles. And on top of all of that, they also had to meet certain science dimensions because of course, mail has to actually fit in these things. So that pretty much describes the mailbox we're talking about. So what if you didn't comply? Like what would happen if you just kept your lard can post it up? Well, you got a warning and that warning was that your service will get cut off if you don't get a compliant box and then you got instructions as to where don't get a compliant box. And then you've got instructions as to where you can get a compliant box. And there were dozen or so models that the USPS had vetted
当然，它们还要高到足以从车辆中够到。最重要的是，它们还必须符合某些尺寸要求，因为信件实际上必须能放进这些东西里。这基本上描述了我们正在谈论的邮箱。那么，如果你不遵守规定会怎样？比如，如果你只是把你的猪油罐头挂在外面会发生什么？你会得到一个警告，那个警告就是，如果你不买一个合规的邮箱，你的服务就会被切断，然后你会得到关于在哪里的指示。如果你不买一个合规的邮箱，你就会得到关于在哪里可以买到合规邮箱的指示。当时大约有十几种由 USPS 审查过的型号
and said, okay, these are suitable for mail. Okay. Well, that sounds like a good start. Like, I mean, if it's not too own, or is it too expensive, like at least they have a few options? Yeah. Yeah. It was a step- the right direction, but it also caused some other side effects, one of which was a conflict of interest because suddenly, you know, people would ask their mail carriers, well, which box should I get? And companies figured out, oh, hey, we could pay these mail carriers a commission to suggest our box. So, um, no, you know, suddenly there's this kind of perverse incentive for male carriers to, you know, mock different boxes. And that wasn't going to work for the USPS.
并表示，好的，这些是适合装信件的。好吧。嗯，这听起来是个不错的开始。我的意思是，如果不是太繁重，或者不是太贵，至少他们有几个选择？是的。是的。这是朝着正确方向迈出的一步，但它也带来了一些其他副作用，其中之一就是利益冲突，因为突然之间，你知道，人们会问他们的邮递员，嗯，我应该买哪个箱子？而公司发现，哦，嘿，我们可以付给这些邮递员佣金让他们推荐我们的箱子。所以，呃，不，你知道，突然之间，邮递员有了一种不健康的动机去，你知道，兜售不同的箱子。这对于 USPS 来说是行不通的。
Totally. Oh, they're taking kickbacks. Oh, so disappointing. Yeah, right. So like, what did they do to solve that problem? Well, basically in the end, they said, okay, no more of this kind of picking out from the list or whatever. The USPS just turned inward to somebody who was already on staff, a guy named Roy, and they said, Roy, make a box. And he made a box. And not just any box, he made one that was basically open source, a design that any company could legally take and make. And so this took the competitive aspect out of the equation.
完全是这样。哦，他们在拿回扣。哦，太让人失望了。是的，对。那么，他们做了什么来解决这个问题呢？嗯，基本上最后，他们说，好吧，不能再这样从名单里挑选或者别的什么了。USPS 转向了内部的一名员工，一个名叫罗伊（Roy）的人，他们说，罗伊，做一个箱子。然后他做了一个箱子。而且不只是任何箱子，他做了一个基本上是开源的箱子，一个任何公司都可以合法采用并制造的设计。因此，这把竞争因素从等式中去除了。
So there were still different companies building the boxes, but there wasn't any real incentive for somebody to recommend one option over the others because they all had the same design. That's so cool. It's so forward thinking of the time to make it open source. So how did Roy come up with this perfect mailbox design that's become the icon of today? Well, a lot of ways he built on what was already there. These guidelines that the USPS had set out,
所以仍然有不同的公司在制造这些箱子，但没有人真正有动机去推荐某个选项而不是其他选项，因为它们都有相同的设计。太酷了。在那个时代，把它做成开源的设计真是太有前瞻性了。那么罗伊是如何想出这个完美的邮箱设计的，并让它成为今天的图标的呢？嗯，在很多方面，他是在现有的基础上构建的。也就是 USPS 设定好的这些准则，
but he also focused on making them simple and cheap so that anybody could afford one. So his box has this arch top to prevent snow and water from accumulating and the curve shape also made mass production easier because it turns out wrapping a curve is easier than precisely bending metal. And then there's that classic front latch which helps protect the male inside. So in the end, he took all these criteria and he made this thing that was functional and
但他也专注于使它们简单且便宜，以便任何人都能买得起。所以他的箱子有一个拱形顶部，以防止积雪和积水，这种弯曲的形状也使大规模生产变得更容易，因为事实证明，包裹曲线比精确弯曲金属要容易。然后是那个经典的前卡扣，它有助于保护里面的信件。所以最后，他吸收了所有这些标准，制造了这个功能齐全、
durable and inexpensive and used as few moving parts as possible. Like you just followed the brief and was a great designer, it sounds like it's just fantastic. So I tend to see these more out in the country and I'm sure I've seen them in cities too and especially in suburbs. So they really weren't just for rural delivery, they really became the mailbox. Right. And that's in part because of this open source aspect, because the design had no patent.
经久耐用、价格便宜且尽可能使用最少活动部件的东西。就像你只是遵循了任务简报，并且是个出色的设计师一样，听起来简直棒极了。所以我往往在乡村地区更多地看到这些，而且我确信我也在城市里见过它们，尤其是在郊区。所以它们真的不仅仅用于乡村投递，它们真的成了邮箱本身的代名词。对。部分原因是因为这个开源的方面，因为这个设计没有专利。
Any company could just make them. And because they worked well, a lot of companies did just that. And it also didn't hurt that the USPS mandated that people use these boxes in rural areas for a while. It wasn't until the late 70s, actually, that they started to relax their restrictions and let people use a variety of box types. Yeah, because I definitely have seen other ones.
任何公司都可以制造它们。由于它们运作良好，很多公司确实就这样做了。而且，USPS 在一段时间内在农村地区强制人们使用这些箱子，这也没有坏处。事实上，直到 70 年代末，他们才开始放松限制，允许人们使用各种类型的箱子。是的，因为我确实见过其他的。
It just, I just see this one a lot, and that's really outstanding, and that explains why. I mean, I guess one of the reasons why it's been so reinforced is that this design is definitely on digital. I mean, you see a profile of that type of box around the top, the little red flag. You know what that means. That means mail.
只是，我经常看到这一个，这真的很突出，这也解释了原因。我的意思是，我想这种设计之所以如此深入人心，原因之一就是这个设计绝对是在数字端存在。我的意思是，你看到了这种箱子顶部的轮廓，还有那面小红旗。你知道那是什么意思。那意味着信件。
Oh, yeah. There's even an emoji called Clues to Mailbox with red flag. And it is absolutely super obviously based on that classic design that was made over a century ago That's so great. So do we know Roy's last name? I believe it's Jorrelman Okay, I'm not sure I'm pronouncing that entirely right so we want to check that before we are air it But uh, but yeah, I believe it is or we could just control them right? Let's just live a little I just kind of you know
哦，是的。甚至有一个表情符号叫做带红红旗的信箱。它绝对非常明显地基于一个多世纪前制作的那个经典设计太棒了。那么我们知道罗伊的姓氏吗？我想是约雷尔曼（Jorrelman）好吧，我不确定我是否完全读对了，所以在我们播出之前我们想核实一下。但是，但是，是的，我相信它是，或者我们也可以就叫他罗伊，对吧？让我们大胆一点，我只是觉得，你知道
I just like the idea of Roy the male guy, you know, sitting there designing his box. Our hero for today is Roy who worked at the USPS and made that mailbox that we all know and love. That's all raised a little male flag to that guy. Absolutely. When we come back, another thing that you've definitely seen along the highways and freeways, those little dots that light the way. After this. So we're back with another story, and this one we actually included in the book, the 99% of visible cities, so actually, know it ahead of time. And it concerns those reflective markers that you see, you know, along the side of roads
我只是喜欢邮递员罗伊坐在那里设计他的箱子的想法。我们今天的英雄是罗伊，他在 USPS 工作，制作了我们大家都知道和喜爱的那个邮箱。让我们向那个家伙升起一小面信件旗帜吧。绝对的。当我们回来时，你会看到另一件在高速公路和快速路上肯定见过的东西，那些照亮道路的小圆点。广告之后见。所以我们带着另一个故事回来了，我们其实把这个故事收录在了《物理城市的 99%》这本书里，所以其实，你提前知道了。它关乎你在路边
or between lanes, there's lots of different kinds, there's lots of different places, and on the world that they exist. But the most interesting character we discovered, who worked on a very early version of these, was a British inventor named Percy Shaw. And with a lot of great origin stories, the details of Percy's breakthrough, they kind of vary depending on who's telling the story, but they all have this one thing in common. It started with him driving along a narrow road, and a foggy night in the early 1900s near his hometown of Halifax. And as his brother told the story, Percy was coming
或车道之间看到的那些反光标志，有很多不同的种类，在很多不同的地方，以及它们存在的世界。但我们发现的最有趣的人物，他曾致力于这些标志的早期版本，是一位名叫珀西·肖（Percy Shaw）的英国发明家。正如许多伟大的起源故事一样，珀西取得突破的细节因讲述故事的人而异，但它们都有一个共同点。这一切都始于 1900 年代初期在他家乡哈利法克斯附近的一个雾夜，他开车行驶在一条狭窄的道路上。正如他兄弟所讲述的故事，珀西当时正
home from one of his usual haunts, a local pub, but as he drove around this sharp corner, he saw the reflective eyes of a cat alongside the road. And because he saw that cat, he avoided driving his car off of a cliff and crashing and probably dying. So normally Percy didn't rely on good fortune and cats crossing his path to stay on the road. He relied on tram lines in the road. They were the metal reflection from the tracks of trams. He would use those to orient himself on the road.
从他经常去的一个地方——当地的一家酒吧开车回家，当他绕过这个急转弯时，他看到了路边猫的眼睛闪闪发光。正因为他看到了那只猫，他才避免了把车开下悬崖并撞毁甚至可能丧命的悲剧。所以通常珀西并不依靠好运和穿过他路径的猫来留在路上。他依靠的是路上的有轨电车轨道。那是来自电车轨道的金属反光。他会利用这些来在道路上定位自己。
But they had been ripped up and so he was stuck kind of squinting through the fog. And that's when it came to him that he wouldn't invent a way to solve this problem for himself and other drivers and not rely on cats. And it was very much in his nature. Percy had always been a fixer and a tinker from a young age. And he actually left school at the age of 13 to help his family make money. And he ended up starting a paving business. And then finally in 1934, he patented this device that would reshape the roads of England and then eventually go global. So his design involved a pair of reflective glass beads embedded in a cast iron frame. These retro reflective cat's eyes, they redirected the light back towards the cars with minimal scattering.
但它们被拆毁了，所以他只能在雾中眯着眼睛辨认。就在那时，他灵机一动，决定发明一种方法来为自己和其他司机解决这个问题，而不依赖猫。这非常符合他的天性。珀西从小就是一个热心的修理工和爱折腾的人。他实际上在 13 岁时就离开了学校，为了帮家里赚钱。他最后开办了一家铺路公司。最后，在 1934 年，他为这个将重塑英国道路并最终走向全球的设备申请了专利。所以他的设计包括一对嵌入铸铁框架中的反光玻璃珠。这些猫眼反光镜以最小的散射将光线反射回汽车。
So you really could see them. They stood out in the dark night. And they were really sophisticated. Like the metal part projected the glass, but it also lowered when cars drove over in both for safety reasons and to create a noise. They alerted the drivers with the noise. And probably my favorite detail, though, is that these little rubber wipers were added later. So basically, when the housing got pushed down, the glass would wipe up against the wipers. And so the device was self-cleaning. All of this is really sophisticated. So it may be obvious, but Shaw didn't invent these overnight, right? He tried out all these different designs and he iterated on them. and one of my favorite parts of
所以你真的能看到它们。它们在黑暗的夜晚格外显眼。而且它们非常先进。就像金属部分保护了玻璃一样，当汽车驶过时，它也会下沉，既出于安全原因，也为了产生噪音。它们用噪音提醒司机。不过，可能我最喜欢的细节是，这些小橡胶雨刷是后来才加上去的。基本上，当外壳被压下去时，玻璃就会在雨刷上擦拭。因此这个设备具有自清洁功能。所有这些都非常先进。所以这可能是显而易见的，但肖并不是一夜之间发明出这些东西的，对吧？他尝试了所有这些不同的设计并在其中进行迭代。故事中最让我喜欢的部分之一
the story is how he approached this design development process. So instead of getting approval and, you know, having authorities sign off on him testing them out, he just went out and started adding his various prototypes to local roads. The good old days, I mean, he did own a paving company, so he just would start ripping up the roads and he would try out different designs. Right. He was perfectly suited to doing this, just not quite legally allowed. But even then, he had another problem too, which is that once he got this designed together, he couldn't seem to find buyers until the Second World War
就是他是如何对待这种设计开发过程的。他没有去寻求批准，你知道的，让有关当局签字同意他进行测试，而是直接走出去，开始将他的各种原型产品添加到当地的道路上。美好旧时光，我的意思是，他确实拥有一家铺路公司，所以他就会开始扒开道路，尝试不同的设计。对。他非常适合做这件事，只是当时并不完全合法。但即便如此，他遇到了另一个问题，那就是一旦他把这个设计做好，似乎就找不到买家，直到第二次世界大战
came along. And suddenly, there are wartime blackouts because of air raids. So nights are darker than ever. Drivers have been instructed to add dimmers to their headlamps and do other things to reduce their visibility on the road. And so accidents are happening. And the government responds at first by painting white lines on the roads and on posts to help people see at night. And then, suddenly Percy, who's been asking to get an audience with the government to see if they are interested,
爆发。突然之间，由于空袭，实行了战时灯火管制。所以夜晚比以往任何时候都黑暗。司机们被指示在车头灯上加装调光器，并采取其他措施来减少他们在路上的能见度。因此事故频发。政府最初的反应是在道路和电线杆上刷上白线，以帮助人们在夜间看清道路。然后，突然之间，一直在请求与政府见面看看他们是否感兴趣的珀西，
has these cat-size that are just perfect, right? They use the illumination from cars to light up. So they don't have like an independent source of light that would attract attention from the skies. And the next thing you know, the government is buying like 40,000 of these things a week. In his own accent, I mean, this is where the design spread internationally. So, you know, the other places they also came up with their own and different solutions to fit their regional needs.
拥有了这些堪称完美的猫眼标志，对吧？它们利用汽车的照明来发光。所以它们没有那种会吸引空中注意力的独立光源。接下来你就会发现，政府每周购买大约 4 万个这种东西。在他的家乡，我的意思是，这就是设计走向国际化的地方。所以，你知道，其他地方也想出了他们自己的不同解决方案来适应他们的区域需求。
Like here in California, this is a huge state and there are lots of climate ranges. There's like hot and sunny places, there's cold and snowy places. You need to use different markers in different places in different times. And some reflectors are recessed into mountain roads, for example, so they don't get scraped up by plows.
就像在加利福尼亞州，這是一個很大的州，有很多不同的氣候區。有炎熱晴朗的地方，也有寒冷多雪的地方。你需要在不同的地方、不同的時間使用不同的標記。例如，有些反光標誌是嵌入山路中的，這樣就不會被鏟雪車刮壞。
So there's lots of things you have to work on. And so these things have been iterated and have different origins, depending on where you have to work on. And so these things have been iterated and have different origins, depending on where you are in the world. Right. And if you think about Percy's cat-size too, that was one of the things that made them work so well in Britain.
所以有很多事情需要你去處理。這些事物經過不斷迭代，有著不同的起源，這取決於你身處世界的哪個地方。沒錯。如果你想想珀西的「貓眼」，那也是讓它們在英國如此成功的原因之一。
It's like Britain is foggy and rainy. And so these wipers were particularly useful. So in a way, they were sort of, they could be universal, but they also were very site-specific as a solution. But no matter where you go, there is this type that's more common than any other. And it's basically just a trapezoid, right? It's got a ramp up on one side, a sort of flat top, and then a ramp down on the other side.
就像英國總是多霧又多雨。因此這些雨刷（指反光標誌）特別有用。所以在某種程度上，它們既可以是通用的，但作為一種解決方案，它們也非常具體地針對特定地點。但無論你去哪裡，都有這種比其他任何類型都更常見的類型。它基本上就是一個梯形，對吧？它的一側有一個斜坡，頂部是平的，然後另一側又是一個斜坡。
Right. So you can see it in the two different interactions, depending on which way you're going down the road. And it's not just the trapezoid shape, it's used in a lot of different places. A lot of the colors are pretty common too. So here in the US, for example, it's really common to have white reflectors, to divide lanes and yellow reflectors
沒錯。所以你可以從兩個不同的互動中看到它，這取決於你是沿著道路往哪個方向走。而且它不只是梯形形狀，它還被用在很多不同的地方。很多顏色也非常普遍。所以，例如在美國，用白色反光標誌來劃分車道是非常常見的，而黃色反光標誌則用在
on the edge of the road. But also there's some variations there too. So like you can have greens and blues, they indicate things that are on the side of the road. So plofstuffs for cops can have a different color, and locations for fire hydrants to signal firefighters are also a different color. Right, and I love the fact that you don't typically notice the color differences. You see the reflectors, but some of them are like queued in to tell different groups about
道路邊緣。但那裡也有一些變化。例如你可以有綠色和藍色，它們代表道路側面的東西。所以警察的標誌可以有不同的顏色，消防栓的位置用來向消防員發信號也是不同的顏色。沒錯，我喜歡這樣一個事實：你通常不會注意到顏色上的差異。你能看到反光標誌，但其中一些是用來提示不同群體關於
what they can find. And then there's this other neat function that they can serve too. Because of their trapezoidal shape, they can have different colors facing different directions. So for example, a reflector can have white on one side and that tells you you're going the right way. And then they can have red on the other side, which lets you know that you're going the wrong way. Very much going the wrong way. It should probably just stop your car, maybe turn around slowly. If there's one lesson from this show,
他們可以找到什麼。然後它們還可以發揮另一個巧妙的功能。由於它們是梯形形狀，它們可以面向不同的方向顯示不同的顏色。例如，反光標誌的一側可以是白色，這告訴你你正在朝正確的方向行駛。然後它們的另一側可以是紅色，這讓你知道你正在逆向行駛。確實是逆向行駛。你可能應該直接停下車，或者慢慢掉頭。如果從這個節目中能學到一個教訓，那就是
it's that if you see red, maybe stop. Maybe stop. Blue also sometimes, but not always, yeah. Yeah. So in the book, we go over all these different details and we talk about different designs and we found a different place is,
如果你看到紅燈，也許就停下來。也許停下來。有時候也有藍色，但並非總是如此，是的。所以，在書中，我們探討了所有這些不同的細節，我們討論了不同的設計，我們發現了不同的地方，
but we really tell the story through Percy Shaw. And then the end Percy became something of a local legend in a Halifax. There's this plaque affixed to his old house and his design, one a bunch of design awards. But he never really seemed to care about all that stuff. And he did travel for work, but he preferred to mostly stay close to home.
但我們主要是透過珀西·肖來講述這個故事。後來，珀西在哈利法克斯成為了一個當地的傳奇人物。他的舊房子上掛著一塊牌匾，他的設計贏得了許多設計獎項。但他似乎從不在乎那些事情。他的確為了工作而出差，但他更喜歡大部分時間待在離家近的地方。
And one of the few ways that you can actually tell he'd become this kind of rich and influential guy was this Rolls Royce phantom. And people would tell stories about him, you know, riding around in it driven by his chauffeur, and often just traveling to and from his favorite pub along those very same roads that inspired him to create this thing that made him, they missed in the first place. So there you have it. That's just one story of over a hundred that we have in the book. And in the 9% of us, we'll see. We have illustrations of all these things too, including Percy's cat's eyes and a variation called bot's dots, which are really common
能看出他已經成為這種富有且有影響力的人的少數跡象之一，就是這輛勞斯萊斯幻影。人們會講述關於他的故事，你知道的，由司機開著車載他在裡面四處轉悠，而且經常只是往返於他最喜歡的酒吧，沿著那些曾啟發他創造這個讓他成名的東西的道路行駛。所以，這就是了。這只是我們書中一百多個故事中的一個。在我們的書中，我們還會看到。我們有所有這些事物的插圖，包括珀西的貓眼以及一種叫做波特點（bot's dots）的變體，這在加利福尼亞非常常見
in California, and those trapezoidal reflectors that we talked about as well. And this is definitely the kind of story you can expect from the upcoming book in general, you know, like we talk about specific designs and places and characters and all the ideas and lessons and histories that are specific to a place, but also have global implications and global meaning. Exactly. And while you're waiting for your copy of said book, I've also been writing up a bunch of articles about how the book was made. And I've been answering a lot of questions people have.
還有我們討論過的那些梯形反光標誌。這絕對是你可以從即將出版的新書中期待的那種故事，你知道的，就像我們談論特定的設計、地點和人物，以及所有特定於某個地方但又具有全球意義和全球內涵的想法、教訓和歷史。沒錯。當你在等待這本書的時候，我也一直在寫一系列關於這本書是如何製作的文章。我一直在回答人們提出的許多問題。
And, you know, I've been gathering some process materials from our Illustrator Patrick Vale and our designer Rapha Rafael Geroni. And so I've been assembling these into some neat surprises and sort of behind the scenes pieces about how we made the book, because of course, we're a design show. So we're not only interested in talking about design in the book, but we're also interested in talking
而且，你知道的，我一直在從我們的插畫家帕特里克·維爾（Patrick Vale）和我們的設計師拉斐爾·熱羅尼（Rafael Geroni）那裡收集一些製作過程的素材。所以我把這些整理成了一些精妙的驚喜以及關於我們是如何製作這本書的幕後花絮，因為當然，我們是一個設計節目。所以我們不僅對談論書中的設計感興趣，我們也對談論
about the design of the book. And some of the process, the iterations that Raphael went through when he was working on the cover, for example, are super fascinating. I even forgot some of the different versions that he did. And the picture is that the drawings are so cool. He should definitely check them out. They're all at nyanipi.org.
這本書的設計感興趣。拉斐爾在設計封面時經歷的一些創作過程和迭代，例如，超級迷人。我都忘了他在不同版本中做了哪些嘗試。而且這些圖片，這些畫作太酷了。你絕對應該去看看。它們都在 nyanipi.org。
And if you want to order the book directly, you just have to go to nyanipi.org slash book. All right, thanks, Kurt. Thank you so much, Trum Roman. It's been a blast. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Kurt Coles Stead with help from Emmett Fitzgerald, music by Sean Rial. Delaney Hall is our senior producer, the rest of the team,
如果你想直接訂閱這本書，你只需要去 nyanipi.org slash book。好的，謝謝，庫特。非常感謝你，羅曼。這太棒了。99% Invisible 本週由庫特·科爾斯特德製作，埃米特·菲茨傑拉德提供協助，音樂由肖恩·里亞爾創作。德蘭妮·霍爾是我們的資深製作人，團隊的其他成員
includes Vivian Leigh, Chris Barube, Joe Rosenberg, Katie Mingle, Abby Madon, Sophia Klatsker, Christopher Johnson, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KLW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, which is basically in our houses and apartments all around the country, but in our hearts will always be. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listener supported podcasts in the world.
包括薇薇安·李、克里斯·巴魯比、喬·羅森伯格、凱蒂·明格爾、艾比·馬登、索菲亞·克拉茨克、克里斯托弗·約翰遜，以及我羅曼·馬斯。我們是舊金山 91.7 KLW 的一個項目，在 Radio Row 製作，這基本上位於全國各地的我們的家和公寓裡，但在我們心中，它永遠在美麗的加利福尼亞州奧克蘭市中心。我們是來自 PRX 的 Radio Topia 的自豪成員，這是一個極具獨立精神的集體，匯集了世界上最具創新性、由聽眾支持的播客。
Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 9.9 PIorg, or on Instagram and read it too. You can pre-order the 99% Invisible City at 99pi.org slash book. We still have a few signed copies and a few coins available. Check out all the details at 999PI.org slash book. And for all your other 99PI needs, look no further than 99PI.org. from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 radiotopia.fm 上找到所有這些內容。你可以在推特上 @我 Roman Mars，或在節目官方賬號 @9.9 PIorg 找到我們，也可以在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上找到我們。你可以在 99pi.org slash book 預訂《99% Invisible City》。我們仍然有一些簽名版和少數硬幣可供購買。請在 999PI.org slash book 查看所有詳細信息。至於你所有的其他 99PI 需求，只需訪問 99PI.org。來自 PRX。本集暫無評論。點擊文字記錄中的任何句子即可發表評論。